good morning everyone
Welcome to our second presentation of
the day in Saint Helens our speaker
today is Pablo Alfaro Paulo is a
renowned machine learning engineer with
over 15 years of experience in several
different Industries meteorology retail
and energy today he will be sharing
um
with us
the demand simulation and forecasting
models and so let's give a war and
welcome to the public
well thank you very much for that
presentation and thanks to the
organizers of baidata for bringing us
all together here it's an awesome
opportunity to do sharing these
experiences with you so well I'm Paulo
Alfaro I'm a senior machine learning
engineer I come from a software
engineering background and have a
mathematical engineering master's degree
I have worked in the energy and
meteorology Industries you know in
energy I did some simulations and
pricing optimization and now I've moved
to retail at Rayo where I'm the pricing
Solutions technical lead
so who are we at Trio where trial loves
is an AI and machine learning consulting
company we specialize in developing the
AI capabilities of our business partners
and you can see here some of the Fortune
500 customers that have trusted us with
their projects We Have Skills across the
entire machine learning stack we have we
can do predicted analytics computer
vision natural language processing and
envelopes and we also have a strong
focus on the pricing and particularly in
the resale Industries so that's what
we'll be talking about today
okay let's start going first into the
pricing problem first who here in the
audience knows a little bit about the
pricing problem okay well nice nice we
can work with that okay let's let's
start with a little bit of motivation
why do we want to do pricing
optimization and the answer is clearly
to maximize profit right we do so in AI
by leveraging data that we have on our
customers Behavior you know to model uh
their pricing decisions and use that to
make better
um their purchasing decisions and you
start to make better pricing decisions
ourselves for example a classical
example of a data driven pricing is
seasonal pricing where jackets sell more
in the winter right and then you can
price accordingly but more modern takes
on that that technology allows us to
capture is for example competitor
changes in prices or you know a YouTuber
recommending our product all of that can
be used to enhance our competitiveness
and gain a larger portion of market
share
so what can we expect for for a business
impact well McKinsey has quoted a two to
five percent sales uplift is typical
with an accompanying five to ten percent
and we actually have deployed one such
technology in one of our customers and
they were expecting a one percent
increase in gross margin but we managed
to deliver 28 so as you can see the
gains can be pretty significative
okay given that motivation what is the
actual pricing problem and pricing
optimization in a nutshell is maximizing
the profit function which is that
function you see there that's composed
of two uh two parts essentially we have
the this blue part which is the demand
you know that is going to be affected by
your pricing decision as well as several
other factors that we can incorporate as
covariants and then you have your unit
margins which is prices minus costs
essentially right the higher your price
the bigger your margin but conversely
the lower your your Demand right the
higher your Price Less people are going
to be willing to purchase your items so
you need to find the trade-off there
that maximizes your total profit
okay so a bit more motivation why do we
want to simulate a market and there's
essentially you know three big things
that that come into play first of all of
them is the expectation you know in a
simulated Market you know what should
happen what what should be happening uh
in it and then you can define a clear
Target for your models to pursue then
you have
times the same situation unless it
debugging and opting tuning models
becomes very difficult because you can't
really you know adapt to the same thing
the final thing is actually measurements
rather than regret but regret is the
most important measure that we'll be
taking and that is I know you know in
this theoretical simulation I know
what's the maximum I could have gained
if I had perfect information you know if
I knew the underlying truth I know what
I would have again but since I have an
imperfect estimate I will make some you
know Delta be below that right that
difference I want to bound and minimize
essentially in order to have a guarantee
that my models are going to perform well
in a while if I don't have that I can
put out models in production that can
have costly mistakes and lead to large
losses
so okay let's go into our Market
simulator and before we start building
it up from scratch we're going to define
a few assumptions uh regarding its scope
so first we are going to you know have
uh some simplifying assumptions and
let's get into them so we'll have a
single item Market that will have no
competitors and Unlimited Supply and you
can see these are fairly restrictive
conditions right that limit the
applicability of this simulation but but
we actually deliberately chose those
situations because we wanted to build a
simulator that was fast to develop and
that could lead us to you know bring
modeling improvements in a short time
frame we were aiming for a three-month
delivery right in terms of modeling
improvements so we wanted a simple to
build simulator versus a more complex uh
you know simulation that would take
years to tune and and and and and
properly model and I hope by the end of
this conversation I can convince you
that this was a good approach
what we didn't want to sacrifice though
is that the expected demand is a
function of price obviously right but
also from other covariants other factors
that may be affecting our simulation
right you can have seasonal effects you
can have Trends you can have you know
other factors that determine the number
of sales your your customers are going
to purchase and we want to be able to
model that and the final thing is
Randomness which is we won't ever be
able to observe every Factor
contributing to the pricing decision of
our customers and the final outcome is
going to be a random realization of our
expected demand we'll see what that
means very shortly
Okay so let's get into it this is the
first component of our Market simulation
which is the expected demand that we can
expect to sell as a function of price
and go budgets and don't worry about the
formulation that's there just for
reference but what matters is the curve
to your right which essentially has the
shape of the of the curve that we're
producing and you can see that it has
some good properties for modeling a
demand curve essentially it is
monotonically decreasing with price so
the higher price the lower I sell it is
it has an elastic region where demand
varies heavily with prices right here in
the middle and then price dominates
exponentially right no matter the value
of alpha if I if I you know increase
price high enough I will kill the sales
so this is important for us to be able
to model and
meters in this function you know we have
Alpha is a proportionality constant so
increasing that value means we sell more
units decreasing it means we sell less
and then we have beta for the slope and
Gamma for the center we can create a lot
of different markets for different kinds
of goods right and using Alpha as a
function of X we can incorporate any
covariates that we want
okay so we have expected demand who know
what about expected profit this is what
we're going to be uh trying to chase so
expect that profit is no more than
multiplying the expected the Mind times
the unit margin right and then the the
wheel to our simulation this red curve
here which essentially is the money that
I can expect to buy if I price at that
point uh in reality right the blue dot
here at the top is the true Optimum uh
Prof expected profit that I can achieve
and its corresponding price is the
corresponding uh Optimum price right
that is what we're going to be targeting
essentially we want to get to that price
okay we talked about expected demand and
profit but in reality we won't you know
even though we may expect to sell two
and a half units of a product every day
we won't really observe you know two and
a half units old on any given day we
will observe two two three four whatever
right but an integral number so in order
to model that as well as that
uncertainty in the customers decisions
we will use a passion distribution from
which we'll sample and the trick here is
that we will use the expected demand
that we defined before as its
conditional expectation so we will have
different conditional expectations for
that poisson distribution from which
we'll sample our realizations and I
don't know how those come across in the
screen in the projector but here are
some little green dots with a truly high
alpha those green dots are the
realizations of the uh the sales that we
will be observing our goal as pricing
agents in the market is going to be
estimating the blue curve from those
green realizations right and yeah and
I'm getting ahead of myself so this is
the the learning agent essentially how
how are we going to get the blue curve
well we're going to do that by using a
regression problem essentially we will
have the number of units we sold as a
function of the price the covariates and
the a set of model parameters and we
will fit those model parameters in order
to minimize an error term right that way
our function f will try to match as
closely as possible the number of units
we sell and then we can use f of price
and coverage to forecast what we will be
selling
okay so we keep adding components to our
simulation now we have a light blue line
uh yeah so this is staircase light blue
line is essentially our forecasted
demand and that is trying to track the
blue underlying demand and then we have
the pink line here which is the
forecasted profit trying to track the
true red profit essentially right and
here at the top you can see this orange
dot is essentially our suggested Optimum
price
right corresponding to the maximum
forecasted profit there right our
optimization problem is going to be
choosing the top point in that pink
curve right okay so we have all the
components we need to the final
simulation how do we tie them all
together well we have this simulation
Loop which is essentially a closed loop
in which we'll start from a set of
marking conditions that is essentially
you know our history of pricing what we
did in the past that is going to produce
the data set that we need to train our
regressor essentially right and we will
use that data to train our regression
model which will in turn use by varying
the price across the entire x-axis in
order to produce that forecasted demand
curve now that we have the demand curve
we optimize the expected profit as a
functional price we make our pricing
decision and we set that upon the market
right after we said that on the market
we observe the market reaction and
reaction and people purchase a certain
amount of goods from our a company that
in turn generates a new data point which
we can use to further refine the model
and the cycle continues essentially
right so how this adult layout well like
this here you can see that the model is
essentially trying different price
points and as it drives new prices the
estimate of the blue curve gets closer
and closer to the true underlying demand
and then conversely the expected profit
also gets closer to the the forecasted
profit gets closer to the expected
profit and finally we come up with the
optimal price decision that matches the
blue dot more closely Okay so we've done
it we're we're true I mean we have a you
know a pricing model that can solve a
lot of problems well not quite actually
there's a few scenarios where this same
model won't be able to converge and if
you notice here
we have our y-axis ranging in the zero
to 250 units right so that means we have
a fast response from the market that
market purchases a lot and we have a lot
of elasticity so if we make a bad
pricing decision we're going to see that
immediately whereas here our Market tops
out at 0.25 units per day
so essentially this is a slow selling
product and that becomes a problem
because we can't tell whether we didn't
sell the product because we set a bad
price or because the product naturally
sells slowly so what it produces is that
we will you know whenever we see a sale
like a confirmation of sales in any
price point the model is actually going
to stay pricing there because it thinks
it will never sell anything at this
location and so it will be stuck in a
suboptimal region and even though we get
perfect accuracy in this region we will
never get to explore this right it will
be stuck there forever missing the
optimum altogether
so okay we we have an exploration
problem and what that means is that we
well we cranked the difficulty up a
little bit more and we defined nine
different scenarios for our for our
agents to try to price on and the
scenarios don't matter that much it's
different locations of the historic
prices with regards to the true Optimum
price and then you know uh fast sales
among curves low sales among curve and
another kind of curve that doesn't have
a flat zone to the left but essentially
out of these nine scenarios we only
managed to get good results in one of
them so imagine our wow at that moment
we were not super thrilled but at least
having the simulator allowed us to
surface this problem right that was true
in our actual models so okay we we know
that we have a problem we know that it's
an exploration problem and how can we
work around that how can we solve it
well uh to do so we will you know borrow
from inspiration from the multi-arm
Bandit problems who here in the audience
knows about multi-around Bandits
okay cool cool cool well multirandities
is a pretty good and super simple
actually reinforcement learning
algorithm in which you have several uh
you know slot machines each of them have
a different payout right and we as
agents need to determine which of the of
the machines pays the most and we can do
so by trying them out you know and
figuring out which one is the better
paying one right to do so what we'll do
is we'll build an an estimate of the
distribution of the expected payout of
the of the machine and as you can see
here you know if this red line is the
true payout a bad sample right if we got
unlucky and got particularly High
samples for this machine can lead us to
the same problem we can you know get an
estimate that's higher than the True
Value and a lower estimate in the in the
true maximum right and we will forever
keep trying this arm because we will
only be focusing on the unexpected
payout here so the way Bandits work
around this and I'm so glad that the
nixler guys came after me because they
explained it to you you all you need to
know about confidence intervals is by
using confidence intervals essentially
we're going to use an algorithm that's
called upper confidence bound which is
built on the principle of an optimism in
the face of uncertainty which is
actually a pretty cool thing and it
essentially states that if you don't
know what will happen you're going to be
optimistic about it and try it out see
what happens right so instead of using
just the average of the distribution
we're going to take the entire
distribution here right and we're going
to look at an upper bound of the of the
of the of that distribution instead of
looking at the mean this upper bound
incorporates the variance that I have in
this box essentially right
and what I'm doing here is explicitly
favoring exploration if I don't know
what is going to happen I'm going to try
that out if I was right then that means
I will get a higher payout here and this
estimate is going to go up so this Army
is essentially going to become more
attractive over time if I was wrong then
I will diminish my uncertainty because
the more samples I get you know the less
uncertainty I have around the mean and
then I can you know ignore the alarm
essentially because that's not paying
enough
cool so with that we have an exploration
algorithm right that can you know
explicitly reward exploration so okay
Bandits use the number of times an arm
has been tried to determine the
confidence interval right but here we
have a slightly different problem prices
are continuous and not a discrete arm
right like in abandoned problem where we
could be in prices and build you know a
discrete sets of prices that we could
try but then we also have the covariates
so we would need now to be in both the
prices and the different levels of the
covariates and that is going to lead to
a very sparse data set from which it's
going to be very difficult to learn
anything essentially so the question
becomes how can we build a confidence
interval for an arbitrary model and we
find an answer for that in a classical
statistic technique which is bootstrap
what is bootstrap then well bootstrap is
actually a way for us to estimate the
distribution of any parameter that we
can sample multiple times and if we see
our form our models forecasts as a
random variable that depends on the on
the samples that I have on my training
set we can estimate the distribution of
the expected forecasted profit
essentially so we do that by sampling
our additional data set we build
multiple bootstrap samples with
replacement there's a proof for why that
works but essentially we're going to
chop our original data set in multiple
subsets with replacement we're going to
trade in different models on each of
those two sets and produce a forecast
for all of them hence getting a
distribution of the forecasted expected
profit and then using any you know we
can extract from that distribution any
parameter that we want in particular a
high quantum
okay and I'm going to show you what that
looks like but first i'm gonna make a
little disclaimer there's a lot more
tricks that we actually needed to make
this converge we won't be able to cover
them here because of timing but if
anybody is interested I'm more than
happy to chat about it afterwards I just
wanted to enumerate this here for you
guys
okay and so
here's our simulation again what we have
added now is these shaded areas that you
can see here and those shaded areas
essentially correspond to the to the
bootstrap quantiles so what we did here
is we drained 30 models instead of one
and produced a forecast for each price
point on each of those 30 models right
getting a distribution of forecasts and
from that I extract the 50 60 70 80 90
on 100 quantiles and those are the
borders of the shaded areas that we show
in the plot right and if you know this
the areas where we have the list data
points usually have the widest
confidence intervals right that is our
uncertainty we are quantifying
uncertainty because we know less what
will happen there because we have fewer
samples so essentially we managed to get
what we want with this bootstrapping
technique and how does it look like now
well like this you can see that the
model is no longer stuck in that high
you know High Sales single observation
but rather it's now drying across and
the entire you know price range and as
it does so it is converging towards the
region of the optimum getting more
performance here in the in particular
you know being more accurate at
determining the the demand curve around
the true Optimum and one thing that's
important is that the difference that we
want to measure is the difference where
between where the orange dot would land
in the red curve minus where the blue
point is that is essentially our regret
right it's the difference between the
maximum that we could have achieved and
what we actually have achieved so as you
can see in a very few steps the model is
actually pricing where when it gets to
this very flat region of the profit
where the differences are minimal so
that's good we actually are hitting you
know the optimum in terms of profit
okay and this plot is actually here to
show you you know what we are capable of
doing with having the simulator we now
compete our model against a multitude of
similarious of simulation scenarios All
In Parallel right so that we can you
know observe the model's strengths and
weaknesses understand what is going on
what is wrong and speed up essentially
our development cycle uh you know our
research and development cycle and it's
not the idea that you guys focus on
every plot at once but what you can see
underlying all these plots is that the
model starts trying out prices and as it
does so it starts getting a more and
more accurate estimate of the blue curve
right which in turn leads it towards
being closer to the optimum and
essentially all the orange dots end up
converging to the true blue blue dots
and so here's our results table again
and now all those red ticks have become
green although thread crosses have
become green thicks so what do we have
here well we have we are tracking the
cumulative profit lost that since the
beginning of the of the simulation
essentially that difference between the
within where the blue dot is in the red
line and where the orange dot would have
landed in the in in the in the red line
in the profit so our regret essentially
how much did I lose in terms of profit
on every step and the percentage of that
accumulated across the entire simulation
and we never lose more than five percent
on the maximum that we could have gained
on any scenario so that's a pretty good
result and the only thing that's you
know left for us to do is that this guy
here actually got the the other metric
that we track here is how many steps we
lost more than five percent of the true
Optimum profit and this guy here got
stuck in a super high a sales number in
a too low price it eventually managed to
you know realize that that price point
was not going to pay that much but since
it got a super high uh number of sales
for one bad realization it got stuck
exploding that price too long
till in the red across table this number
was one percent so you know 80 is not
fantastic but we're much better than we
were before
so okay uh some closing remarks well I
wanted to end this presentation with a
quote by uh George box which says that
all models are wrong but some are useful
and that is kind of the the
justification for the choices we made
when we designed our simulation
essentially we wanted a simple model
that we could build you know and use
that to start gaining insights on our
true models which is what we are
actually building
so what have you achieved during this
presentation well we have presented some
key pricing Concepts and built a simple
but expressive formulation of a market
simulator that allows us to model
several item realities we've defined and
implemented a native pricing agent and
used the simulator to find its
limitations and find scenarios in which
it wouldn't work we generalized the
upper confidence bound algorithm to an
arbitrary agent that can include
covariates and can manage to balance
exploration and exploitation exploring
the true demand carbon finding the
optimum location there and we use the
simulator to validate our claims among
the diverse range of Market scenarios
where we got excellent performance
leading us to be happy
actually wanted to show you if anybody
is
in there that's called mastering pricing
strategies that's on the trial Labs blog
post we have the first blog post out
already which covers you know the
building of the simulation and then
we're going to develop a few more of
these ideas
regarding bootstrap and that there so if
you guys can are interested you can
check that out so that's all I had to
say and I'm open to questions
[Applause]
hey thank you that was pretty cool can
you talk about markets that are
non-monopolistic where you have
competitors yes well actually we have in
our oh well let me uh no the question is
recorded right in the mic yeah okay so
okay the question was about
non-monopolistic markets where we have
competitors so we have in our roadmap
for the simulator 2.0 a way to
incorporate a competitors in the in the
simulation and the way we want to do
that is we will have an arrival rate of
customers to our market right so every
sometime we sample a new customer
reaches the market that customer is
going to have a an evaluation uh
function of all the offers that are
available in the market so price is
going to be a factor there but then also
it's going to be you know quality of the
good and selling my ratings you know my
my Antiquity as a seller right several
stuff that can guide the customer's
pricing decision the customer is going
to compare his valuation across all
competitors and keep the competitor that
has the maximum valuation and then he's
comparing that valuation against his own
threshold and if the evaluation exceeds
the threshold he makes the purchase so
with that you can incorporate a
competition into your Market simulation
and the tricky part about that is that
you need to build your engine to be
event oriented instead of every fixed
time steps like we have here which is
much much simpler right so that's a kind
of why we didn't get into that yet but
we have it in in a real map for the next
iteration yeah totally
any other questions
maybe an interesting remark behind
competition markets is that you have a
hyper elastic Zone in your demand curve
When You Reach the the competitor price
essentially your demand drops to zero or
a little bit higher if you are a good
seller right but your demand drops to
zero very sharply so that is a
complication for the for the regressor
agent uh to learn the demand curves yeah
how do you handle codependence where the
price of some products might influence
is might influence the price of other
ones that are natural complements to it
right yeah that's another thing that we
wanted to explicitly avoid with a single
item Market
that's a tricky one and that's a tricky
one and essentially the way
we've been working around that is why
incorporate you know
the best way we found to incorporate
that into the learner agent is by
manually defining a set of competing
products you know you need to use some
clustering techniques in order to
determine that you know my cells go down
when these sales go up or conversely
right and then you have this set of
competitor products and you can
incorporate you know statistics about
their distribution of prices into your
covariate set so you can do for example
the average price of my competitor
products the maximum price the minimum
price right all of that and with that
you give your your learner agent an idea
of what products that are complementary
to yours are doing and that can help you
you know understand it it's the man
yep
but simulating that is a lot more tricky
because you need to you know specify
that the dependence in demand between
those products and getting that right is
a lot more difficult yeah
yeah thank you for the presentation so I
see most of your slides were the doing
the analysis between the price and the
Demand right so are there any other
factors or variables to uh to be
utilized by the uh simulator to to reach
to the optimal pricing point right uh
well we that's also in our roadmap we
haven't covered yet uh incorporating the
covariates in the simulation but we
already have implementations for
incorporating like seasonal patterns
within the within the the Manker right
well variety Alpha so that it can go up
and down every seasonal cycle we also
want to investigate Trends and shocks
you know something abrupt changed and
the man has jumped to a new location
altogether starting this time step and
what we expect is going to be useful
there is for getting the past
essentially I can't you know base my PR
my demand curve estimates based on what
happened like a year ago I need to learn
from what have and in the very short
term so I can end up faster to those
kinds of signals yeah
um how does the model handle things
maybe where you have very sparse data
sets so where it's a brand new item so
there aren't a lot of sales and there
isn't a lot of observations for Price or
where price just doesn't change very
often right well there's two parts to
that question so the question was about
how do you handle a sparsity in the data
set you know where you have few
observations of prices for the item or
even none right the first thing you can
do is find similar products that you
know unsimilar comes in terms of other
covariates that you may have right we
used to price for for a clothing company
so you know scarves would have more or
less similar components right things
like those can help your model
understand the amount of the of the new
product then the other thing is that
having an exploration agent is super
important because it allows you to
actually discover the data that you're
missing right so that's that's kind of
what I was trying to tell you that we
found that usually the the past data is
a very poor representative of the of the
true underlying demand curve and you can
see that in that scenario here remember
I blew past it
here like if you see the thoughts you
would never say that's the demand curve
right underlying that but so the ancient
essentially starts with data that's not
representing what you want to to to
estimate so the exploration component of
the agent is is a key plays a key role
in in discovering those prices
yeah
thank you for the talk uh I had a more
technical question in terms of what
libraries and I assume python since
you're here that you're using to this
and your experience with them
well we for building this it's pretty
much numpy and exubus and we have a
little bit of pandas because it makes it
easier to keep track of what variables
what uh but essentially it's only that
we are actually looking into conformal
prediction because bootstrap has the
disadvantage that it's slow you need to
train 30 models in order to get that
distribution so conformal prediction
seems like a good opportunity to make
that a you know distribution estimate a
lot faster so we're looking into that
and the other things that we want to try
are things like outdoor glue on that was
presented here yesterday as well right
where you can have you know a bigger
battery of models trained to do the
regression problem yeah but
that's more or less it
so we built it from scratch using numpy
pandas and actually boost mostly we you
know we started from the um
from no the other way around
we used a template method you know the
programming uh like the design pattern
template method where we built you know
each of these steps in the in the
simulation loop as a placeholder and
then we started filling out you know
what needed to happen in each of these
steps of the simulation uh yeah and we
have a you know we have a framework
which allows swapping one model for the
other very simply write stuff like those
yep
any other questions for Paulo
awesome thank you Pablo can we give a
big round of applause thank you very
much